hey 42 here are we alone in the universe
as big as big questions go it's one of
the biggest we've yet to know the idea
that over Advanced civilizations might
be out there somewhere peering up at
some of the same Stars we do through
their freaky eyes is incredibly
intoxicating
but the truth is finding over
intelligent species remains a distant
dream quite literally imagine a million
civilizations with human level
technology living right here in our very
own galaxy The Milky Way that sounds
like a lot right we'd be dodging et's
every time Elon Musk launched a rocket
but as is often the case the sheer
enormity of outer space makes a mockery
of human intuition
in reality if there were a million
civilizations evenly distributed
throughout the Milky Way our nearest
neighbors wouldn't be hanging out just
around the corner but about 300 light
years away that's a distance so vast we
might never have the technology to blast
warp or teleport across it
you guys know that I love history and I
especially love historically accurate
war games which is why I'm a huge fan of
Warpath in Warpath you can do battle on
the ground and in the air in iconic
locations all around Europe to emerge
victorious in this classic real-time
strategy game the maps in the game are
based on the real world and the PVE
gameplay simulates famous historical
battles so you can return to the
battlefield and alter the course of
history personally I really like the
social aspect of Warpath you can develop
your Reliance and fight side by side
with your brothers in arms fighting with
your friends and alongside your alliance
really makes you experience the
camaraderie that brothers and arms have
on the battlefield oh in the new update
5.0 is coming out where you can use a
sniper and play in first person point of
view Warpath has online tournaments for
players and everyone can participate new
players will compete with game Power and
Senior players can invite a friend and
join as a team to compete with their
total game Power the prize pool is up to
fifteen thousand dollars and everyone
has the chance to win click the link in
the description to play war path today
it's a great game and by using the
special link in the description it
really helps out my channel so don't
miss out and thanks to Warpath for
sponsoring this video as of today the
furthest man-made object from Earth is
NASA's Voyager 1 Pro which left our home
planet in 1977. in the four in a bit
decades since despite traveling at a
fairly nippy 17 kilometers per second
Voyager 1 hasn't even made it a single
light day from Earth let alone a light
year
so those alien neighbors I mentioned the
ones that live 300 light years away yeah
it would take Voyager five and a half
million years to pay them a visit and
that's just one tiny probe not a
monolithic Colony ship capable of
transporting the thousands of people
necessary to prevent inbreeding mega
death during a trip between the Stars
what I'm trying to say is the universe
is colossal and whilst it's by no means
out of the question that we might one
day detect aliens out there amongst the
Stars the chances of us actually
Crossing are pretty much nothing well
not unless they approach us first and if
that happens we may end up wishing they
hadn't luckily to meet ourselves some
aliens we might not have to venture too
far from our home star because it turns
out there's a decent chance they might
already be living amongst us well okay
not exactly amongst us more like just
down the road and no I'm not talking
about the Facebook headquarters
you see scientists are becoming
increasingly optimistic that alien life
might already exist in our solar system
though admittedly these otherworldly
life forms are unlikely to be anything
other than simple microorganisms if
there was another Advanced civilization
just chilling out on Saturn we'd
probably have noticed it by now
microscopic aliens might sound a little
less exciting than I don't know the Borg
but finding a single alien microbe
clinging bravely to the surface of a
world other than our own would be one of
the single biggest moments in human
history not only that it would
fundamentally change our understanding
of the entire universe
let me explain
at the moment we essentially have no
idea whatsoever how common life is maybe
we're entirely alone in the universe or
we could just be one of quadrillions of
different life forms living on hundreds
of trillions of different planets
that isn't hyperbole either it genuinely
is that wide open
finding life elsewhere in our own solar
system would dramatically and
instantaneously change that picture
because if life evolved independently
twice in the very same solar system it
would be an incredibly strong indicator
that life is Rife the and that would be
an absolute Game Changer after all it's
starting to look like planets with
habitable conditions are pretty common
according to a 2020 study there might be
as many as 300 million of them in our
galaxy alone
in other words finding life here in our
own solar system even simple life would
all but confirm that we have a lot of
Neighbors
so yeah it's probably worth having a
look the only question is
where's the best place to start
to the uninformed Observer Venus might
not seem like an obvious place to go
looking for aliens to be honest even to
an informed Observer things don't look
all that promising we're talking about a
planet shrouded in clouds of
concentrated sulfuric acid with surface
temperatures of about 500 degrees
Celsius that's hot enough to melt lead
oh and any Plucky alien visiting Venus
would also be under a lot of pressure
not from his petulant alien boss but the
kinds of pressure only found at 1 000
meters below sea level here on Earth
in other words Venus is pretty much the
dictionary definition of uninhabitable
it isn't but you get the point it's the
kind of planet a Sith Lord might build a
base on just to look like a badass in
front of all his siffy mates
but here's the thing Venus hasn't always
been a brutal hellscape
not long ago our neighbor Planet may
have been well a bit more neighborly
with a temperate climate and liquid
water on its surface even better
according to a 2019 study by NASA these
positively Pleasant conditions probably
persisted for upwards of three billion
years
that's more than enough time for life
too well find a way
of course given the conditions found on
Venus today it's highly unlikely any
life lingered for this long
unless back in 2020 British scientists
observing Venus's fiery atmosphere
detected something they didn't expect to
detect
traces of a gas called phosphine the
fine stunned the scientific world and
once they came to they realized that on
terrestrial planets like Earth and Venus
phosphine is only created through
biological processes
in other words if there's phosphine on
Venus that means there's life on Venus
but before you go and hang out your
first Contact bunting I should probably
mention that the whole phosphine on
venous thing is a little bit
controversial and several recent studies
disputes the findings still we can't yet
refute that life once existed on Venus
and with no fewer than six missions due
there in the next 10 years or so who
knows we might just find it if not Venus
maybe Mars is where we'll find our first
well martians there's a whole bunch of
evidence supporting the idea that liquid
water once flowed on its surface in
significant quantities and thanks to
NASA's Curiosity Rover we also know that
organic compounds examples of Prebiotic
chemistry are found there too
sadly like Venus the red planet isn't
exactly a great holiday destination
these days average surface temperatures
hover at around minus 60 degrees Celsius
and the atmosphere is incredibly thin
with surface pressures about one percent
of those found on Earth Mars also lacks
a magnetic field meaning it gets
absolutely blusted with ionizing
radiation which is lethal to life
that's the bad news the good news is
that if life has ever existed on Mars
there's a pretty decent chance we'll be
able to find it the planet isn't
tectonically active meaning the majority
of its surface is more than 3.5 billion
years old in other words it's one giant
time capsule theoretically then traces
of ancient life lie tantalizingly tucked
away in this big red Treasure Trove
as I say these words NASA's perseverance
Rover is trundling around the Martian
surface patiently bustling up Rock
samples for a return to Earth in the
early 2030s where they'll be examined by
the best Labs ever built by humans
if Mars was ever home to alien life we
have an excellent chance of proving it
within the next decade or so
when we talk about the search for alien
life we tend to focus our attention on
planets I guess that's understandable we
have pretty strong confirmation bias
you're looking at it
but whilst Mars and Venus may have been
habitable Millions even billions of
years in the distant past it turns out
that some of our own solar systems more
than 200 moons may still be habitable
right now for a long time the most
promising of which was Jupiter's moon
Europa
and whilst its claim to that title is
perhaps flimsier than it used to be
mostly because of another fascinating
Moon I'll tell you about in just a
minute
there's no denying that Europa has got
an awful lot going for it
because hidden beneath the moon's icy
crust is a vast ocean and I really do
mean vast according to our current best
estimates europa's Global ocean averages
a staggering 100 kilometers Deep by
comparison Earth's oceans are on average
just four kilometers deep
to put that another way it's estimated
to contain roughly twice as much water
as can be found in all of Earth's oceans
put together despite being smaller than
our own Moon
even better scientists believe this
ocean is in direct contact with europa's
Rocky core allowing nutrients and other
chemical goodness to dissolve into the
water where they could be used by any
alien microbes that happen to be living
there
surface temperatures on Europa can drop
to minus 220 degrees Celsius for context
the coldest temperatures ever recorded
on earth is about -90 but tidal force is
generated by the never-ending
gravitational tug of war between Jupiter
and its many moons cause Europa to warp
and flex generating heat through
friction
[Music]
as of today there are still plenty of
unknowns it's unclear exactly how warm
europa's subsurface ocean might actually
be and we don't know the pH or salinity
of the water it contains and we aren't
really sure what chemistry can be found
down there even so there's every chance
that this icy moon is habitable the
trouble is even if the Hidden World
beneath europa's Frozen crust is
positively brimming with alien life
actually finding it is going to be a
monumentally difficult task
Europa lies at an average distance of
about 630 million kilometers from Earth
significantly further than the likes of
Venus on Mars when NASA's Flagship
Europa Clipper Mission blasts off for
the Jupiter system in 2024 it'll be a
good five and a half years before it
actually gets there and even when it
does it won't be looking for life at
least not directly because if there
really are aliens living on Europa
they're buried beneath up to 30
kilometers of ice that's so cold it's
harder than granite
that would be a serious engineering
challenge to get through here on Earth
but on a frozen Moon 630 million
kilometers away it's an obstacle we
simply aren't equipped to overcome just
yet
if Europa was the long-time poster child
in the hunt for extraterrestrial life in
our Cosmic backyard
Enceladus one of Saturn's frankly
excessive 82 moons is very much The
Pretender to the crowd
which is surprising because on paper it
doesn't actually look all that
impressive for one thing it's absolutely
bloody tiny with a diameter of just 500
kilometers you could comfortably plonk
it down in between London and Edinburgh
and its gravity is so weak that if you
stood on the surface of Enceladus and
fired a gun directly upwards the bullet
would simply carry on into outer space
thanks to this undeniable weediness and
the fact that Saturn is a good 10 times
further away from the Sun than Earth for
a long time scientists assumed Enceladus
would be nothing more than a tiny Frozen
blob with whatever heat it may once have
held in its core having lungs since
dissipated but that all changed in 2005
when NASA's Cassini probe did a flyby of
Enceladus and it observes something
remarkable
plumes of water being fired out into
space from the moon's Southern Pole
the find was so unexpected that
cassini's mission orders were changed
immediately with the probe taking a new
direction to fly through this watery
ejection
and what it found was salt water
compelling evidence that much like
Europa enceladus's Barren icy crust
hides a big wet secret a subsurface
ocean not only that Cassini also
detected simple organic compounds
potential building blocks of life
as an interesting aside it turns out
that little Enceladus has been pumping
out so much water into space that it's
single-handedly created one of Saturn's
rings known as the e-ring
scientists had spent decades wondering
why it was that Enceladus appeared to be
orbiting Saturn smack bang in the middle
of this giant ring and as soon as
Cassini picked up those plumes the
mystery was solved
anyway towards the end of cassini's
mission its instruments made one last
important observation evidence of active
hydrothermal vents bubbling away in the
depths of enceladus's subsurface ocean
that was a huge deal because many origin
of life scientists believe it was around
exactly these kinds of vents that
inanimate matter first sprang into life
right here on Earth billions of years
ago
the evidence is still being pieced
together but there's a growing feeling
that part of enceladus's ocean might
actually be habitable to complex life
and even some extremophile
microorganisms found on Earth today
which is why it's no exaggeration to say
that right now this tiny Moon of Saturn
is very probably the single most
promising place in the entire solar
system for us to go and bag ourselves
some bona fide aliens
of course any attempt to go and do just
that will face many of the same issues I
talked about in the context of Europa on
average Saturn is almost twice as far
away from Earth as Jupiter is so
guessing there's an absolute ball Lake
and much like on Europa if there is any
life to find kilometers of solid ice
will need to be mined the
course there is one key difference here
Enceladus is helpfully blasting its
water from its Subterranean prison clean
out into space meaning we won't need to
drill through one of the Solar System's
biggest ice cubes to get our hands on
some samples
but sadly with zero missions planned for
Enceladus we aren't likely to find out
anytime soon if there is life within
this tiny Moon
Enceladus may be the most likely place
to find life in our backyard but for my
money the most exciting is another moon
in the Saturn system Titan
cars the name suggests Titan is a chunky
boy Saturn's largest moon and the second
largest in the entire solar system after
Jupiter's Ganymede Titan is almost as
big as Earth and bigger than Mercury
but it isn't Titan's planet-like size
that's got me all scientifically hot and
bothered it's the fact that Titan just
so happens to be the only body in our
solar system aside from Earth where
stable bodies of liquid water are found
on the surface
it's a world with wind rain and distinct
Seasons all of which combine to create a
landscape that's surprisingly similar to
that found on Earth with rivers Deltas
Lakes seas and sand dunes
Titan's also the only moon in the solar
system known to have a dense atmosphere
so far so brilliant but there is one
small catch there's always a catch you
see the rivers lakes and seas that dots
Titan's surface aren't full of water
they're flowing with liquid hydrocarbons
like methane and ethane
for that reason alone the surface of
Titan most certainly isn't a candidate
for Life as we know it but it may well
be a candidate for something different
at the start of this video I said that
finding life elsewhere in the solar
system would pretty much guarantee the
existence of Untold billions of other
life forms throughout the Universe and
that's absolutely true
except for one small problem if we were
to find evidence of Life on Mars for
example it wouldn't necessarily mean
that life had originated there
independently there's always a small
chance it hitched a ride from Earth or
vice versa as an example when the
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
smashed into our planet 66 million years
ago its jock of such force that it
blasted billions of tons of debris clear
out into space some of that material
will have crash landed elsewhere in the
solar system potentially taking some
stowaway extremophile microorganisms
with it that could have ceded other
parts of the solar system with life from
Earth
the concept of Life traveling from
planet to planet in this way is known as
panspermia which is a fancy way to say
we impregnated the neighbors and as of
today it's very much a fringe Theory
that's well outside the scientific
mainstream for the simple reason that no
real evidence backs it up but if we were
to find life elsewhere in the solar
system particularly if that life bore
any similarities to life forms found
here on Earth it would certainly lend
more weight to the argument
if we found life on the truly alien
world of Titan however we could be
incredibly confident that panspermia
wasn't the cause Titan is a world
governed by entirely different rules and
Earth life would have no hope of
surviving its methane rain and
hydrocarbon Seas that's actually one of
the biggest challenges we're going to
face when searching for life on Titan if
we do find it it'll be so different to
anything we've ever seen on Earth
we might struggle to recognize as his
life in the first place as intriguing as
the question of whether life could be
possible on a moon like Titan we're
going to have to wait until at least 20
34 to get any answers that's when NASA's
dragonfly mission is due to arrive there
with the express aim to hunt for life
that's one of the most frustrating
things about the search for
extraterrestrial life even here in our
very own solar system the distances
involved are so great that everything
takes bloody ages not to mention the
fact that space exploration costs a
pretty penny NASA has cost a US
Government about 650 billion dollars
since its Inception in 1958.
and yet we humans are a curious bunch
and collectively we've decided that the
possibility of learning more about the
universe we find ourselves in is worth
the time effort and cost
even as I'm speaking probes are
streaking through the solar system
heading to many of the planets and moons
I've covered in this video
will they find life when they get there
your guesses has got us mine but I for
one can't wait to find out
[Music]
thanks for watching
[Music]